Kubo in the two strings is the latest
stop-motion animated film from the
studio like oh you know them from films
like Coraline ParaNorman and the
boxtrolls and this film tells the story
of a young boy named Kubo who through
various circumstances that i don't want
to ruin for you finds himself on an
adventure with a monkey and a beetle
searching for three very specific
objects that he believes he can use to
do battle against an evil force from his
past if you guys know anything about me
you know that I love animation but I
specifically love stop-motion animation
a lot I love this art form I have ever
since I was a kid the early days of old
animated shows like bump in the night to
newer things like Wallace and Gromit
and then Leica came along with their
beautiful films and have blown me away
consistently save for the boxtrolls
which I thought was just fine but
ParaNorman was fantastic and Coraline to
me is one of the best animated films
ever made and I liked Kubo even more
than Coraline for me this is like his
best film so far and I am a huge fan of
their studio similar to Zootopia earlier
this year this movie reminded me why I
love animated films so much this is a
glorious beautifully animated film that
rarely has a dull moment in fact it
doesn't this movie is constantly
entertaining this is such a well
directed movie too even though I am such
a big fan of Leica I just didn't expect
this movie to be as thoughtful or mature
as it was and to use various themes that
I think a lot of the kids that saw this
movie with me in the same audience
probably aren't even going to pick up on
yet until they're older but that's okay
because this is also an action-packed
extremely fun adventure film that can
work on multiple levels you can watch
this movie as a more mature film or you
can enjoy the adventure and the
spectacle because it is beautiful to
look at the voice work is all uniformly
great the animation as I've already said
I could sing its praises forever it's
fantastic to look at and the amount of
work that's put into these movies is
absolutely staggering
and it's never been more impressive in
any of Lycus films than it is in this
one the action sequences are extremely
fantastic the characters are also very
entertaining the monkey
especially stole the entire film for me
you're going to love the monkey she's
awesome
it's also a film brimming with
imagination that asks kids to be
imaginative to use their imagination and
to think beyond our own physical world
that's in front of us and to think about
other more important things as well
which is a hugely important message for
kids and adults I have but one small
issue with this movie and it's once the
main villain is revealed his motivation
for being evil and for doing what he's
doing is very murky and kind of unclear
and doesn't really make sense I get it
from the perspective that the film is
telling me as I watch it but it just
doesn't really connect with me as a
clear motivation for doing what he's
doing before I started filming this
review I was like should I say what I'm
thinking but I'm thinking it so I'm
going to say it I honestly think that if
Leica continues on this level of
animation on this a level of
storytelling for the next few years in
the next few decades I think we might
have the next studio ghibli on our hands
these guys are making quality films and
my god Kubo is a beautiful one I'm going
to give it an a guys besides the fact
that this movie is really that good I
strongly suggest seeing it because like
us films simply don't make enough money
and they need to it's one of the biggest
reasons why Studio Ghibli had to close
its doors they just weren't making
enough money Lika needs to make some
money because they are making some of
the best animated films out there go see
this movie this weekend support them
it's worth your time guys I also really
know that my promotion with audible is
still going on if you go to audible.com
slash Chris you can try their service
for 30 days for free and view their
entire selection of audiobooks you can
listen to them on your mp3 player your
computer iPad iPod whatever device you
enjoy listening to things on you can
probably play your audio books on it
they have such a great selection
hundreds of thousands of audiobooks and
if you don't have the time to sit down
and read but you love reading or you
want to read at work if you can this is
the way to go go to audible.com slash
Chris for a 30-day free trial thank you
very much for audible for continuing to
sponsor my videos and thank you
you you guys for being awesome you're
the best and as always as you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes